did you
did you come across any surprises
yourself when you're writing this book
like anything that kind of blew you away
when you're putting it all together
yeah it not really because i'm jaded and
i'm cynical i don't have a heart but it
was
it was worse than i thought it would be
i mean and i even went to my actuary
because
if you didn't know i had an actuary to
like calculate my figures and double
check my math and like do some
especially with a cross-correlation
between different traits and all that
um i would go to him like did i did i
miss a decimal point
like it is and it that's what was
it was it was worse than i thought
uh but it just reconfirmed everything i
experienced like for example
um there are three guys out there now
who have done uh
kind of like a tree node uh where
they've done online dating
and um i i forget you know the three
different
uh analyses were done
and it was something like okay ten
thousand swipes uh
right and then how many got
matches and it immediately goes to less
than ten percent and then out of the ten
percent that matched
uh what percent uh responded back and
what percent that that and it
and out of i think it was 16 000 a guy
had three
in-person dates and was that the guy
that um
did that infographic yeah yeah and he's
not the only one there's there's three
of them out there and
and this the dad i had at the point in
time and i'm sure
somebody would um there's other men out
there who probably doing the same thing
but there were three guys
one in particular i think was a
statistician and he he kept pretty good
numbers as well
uh and that was that was what was
shocking to me where
you're swiping all the time uh on
online dating and out of 16 000 you get
three dates and lord knows that's not
going to lead to
anything else you know it's not going to
be your wife or anything
and then also related to that another
thing that i was shocked with
is uh the average man do you know what
the average man spends
on online dating
timewise time per day you know i'm gonna
say
a couple hours a day probably 90 minutes
a day 90 minutes yeah
yeah and i'm like uh you got other
things to do guys
you you i mean and for such a low rate
of return
uh where it's nothing it's like you you
might as well i mean you know troy
francis go out and meet these girls in
public
um so that was another shocking thing is
like where's that data come from is that
something that tinder published or
bumble or something no it was it was a
news article
so lord knows what the methodology was
it's the data we have
so if uh if we get better data i could
do but they estimated men are spending
like 85 minutes and women are spending
90 minutes
a day on online dating of course women
are pursuing that for
uh validation and ego feeding but
men are wasting i cannot emphasize that
you are
wasting an hour and a half a day 10 of
your waking hours
uh trying to do online dating it's just
it's pointless it's useless
yeah and you know your typical reward is
gonna be somebody that looks nothing
like their pictures
usually 10 to 20 percent heavier than
their pictures
right and quite unpleasant often with a
feminist degree um that's probably going
to hate the patriarchy right
and i don't know about you but i have
some younger buddies and maybe not so
younger buddies but they're still out
there dating
and they're you know and i didn't
believe it like it can't be that bad
and then also my buddy dre or uh fred
or my buddy chad uh elkins they'll send
me these dating profiles of these gals
and i know they're i know this is not
your average dating profile but the fact
these profiles exist and in
such numbers that are so
delusional like mother of three swipe
left if you have a pro like
even the ones like it's been more than
one where uh
baby on the way it's like oh yeah what
what
what really yeah if you follow me on
twitter you'll see them
i mean oh yeah yeah no you post them
yeah people send send to me all the time
and
and like i only post about 10 of them
like i get a lot
like there's a lot coming through so
those are the ones that people send to
me
it's i mean you're you're not picking
from the best of the best anymore this
is uh
i mean you know the flip side of the
token there's a lot of weak weak gas
beta men too that
that you know really aren't spoiled for
choice either
right well and i always try to have like
this intellectual honesty about me and
like okay look the internet is a very
fine net
and we can drug you know this was always
there's always crazy people out there
and
you say all right is it just because the
internet now catches these crazy ladies
but then uh you know again as a social
scientist of
of sorts should we be seeing like a
bunch of
june cleavers then of the equal amounts
like okay if we're gonna go
bell distribution off to the left of
degenerate worthless pieces of crap
where it's like uh
mom to be child on the way
uh student loan debt tattoos nose
piercing and all that other stuff
well should there be like you know a
svelte
nice good uh christian girl or amish
girl and looking to
you know engineering major something
like that and there is not that
uh commensurate uh high quality women as
well
so you know again it's a very fine net
and you like oh is it you know i think
we're just pulling up the worst that
obviously
we would say look at this crazy you know
like that's going to go to the forefront
but the lack of quality women
as an encounter and opposite to all
these bad ones
is an indication to me like how bad
things are
uh that we for i don't know show me a
girl who's like hey i love guns and i
love jesus and uh by the way i drink
whiskey you know like
i haven't seen that dating profile yet
uh but by gosh there's hundreds if not
thousands of
literally mother expecting mother to be
by the way six feet tall
it's like wow so it's very telling
and and the numbers i have in my book
are kind of bearing that up
you